thank you very much for joining us
iran has reported an accident at its
main nuclear facility
at natanz tehran's atomic agency says it
affected the site's electrical
distribution grid
power was out across the facility's
above-ground workshops and
underground enrichment holes on saturday
president hassan rouhani said tehran had
launched new advanced
enrichment centrifuges at the site this
is after several centrifuges were
damaged in a fire last
year an incident tehran called an act of
sabotage
and iran is high on the agenda as the
u.s secretary of defense lloyd austin
visits israel
tensions in the region have been
escalating in recent weeks
the tehran of today possess
a strategic threat to international
security
to the entire middle east and to the
state of israel
and we will walk closely with our
american allies
to ensure that any new agreement
with iran will secure the vital
interests of the world
of the united states prevent dangerous
arm raising our region
and protect the state of israel harry
foster is in west jerusalem and we'll
have more on the u.s defense secretary's
visit in just a moment but first we go
to our
tehran correspondent assad big assad so
what more are iranian authorities saying
about this
incident accident at the natanz facility
well let me just update you with what
we're the latest that we're hearing now
a written statement has been given by
the head of iran's atomic agency to the
iranian media here ali akbar salehi
now what he said is an admission that
this is not an accident
this is an attack now he didn't use
those words but what he said is today's
act
against the enrichment facilities shows
the failure of those that
oppose iran's nuclear progress it also
shows the failure of those
that oppose iran's negotiations to have
those sanctions lifted
he went on to say that the international
community in the iaea
must confront this nuclear terrorism and
that iran
has a right to respond to those behind
the attack and those that ordered it
now this has come after we first
initially
heard that this was an incident it was
being investigated we thought it was an
accident
but suspicious nevertheless some
lawmakers here said that there was a
possibility that it could have been
sabotaged
or infiltration now this is the head of
iran's atomic organization
clearly now saying that this is more
than just an accident this is
uh an attack and it comes just a day
after iran
uh began gave the news that it was using
advanced centrifuges to enrich uranium
and this is coming as the u.s is about
to resume
nuclear talks with tehran on the 2015
nuclear deal
how might it affect the discussions and
negotiations
well it's definitely going to complicate
matters if iran feels that it is
being under attack by by israel
because that's where the finger is being
pointed although lawmakers and aliya
prasadi
haven't pointed directly at israel but
earlier this week on tuesday an iranian
ship
was attacked in the red sea and from
reports
israel is said to be behind that now
iran's nuclear facility has been
attacked before there's an act of
sabotage according to the iranians
last year in the summer but again iran
wants to go back
and wants these sanctions lifted and
aliyah salihe is saying
that this act is carried out by those
that oppose iran's negotiations and
oppose those sanctions
being lifted so it will definitely
complicate those talks
uh and make them even more difficult
than they already are
thank you very much for that assad big
live forest there in tehran let's get
the view now from jerusalem and speak to
harry fossett
harry as assad said there iran seems to
be pointing the finger of blame at
israel and i know this iranian nuclear
issue is featuring high on the agenda of
discussions
between israeli leaders and the visiting
u.s defense secretary but they're not on
the same page when it comes to
the iranian nuclear issue
very much not and this is the key
difference between what
uh was there under the trump
administration and the situation
now uh that president biden has been
sworn in and
not just not just on the same page
between the u.s and israel it's not
clear that
all of the israeli government is on the
same page given what we heard
at the top of the show from the defense
minister benny gans now of course he's
in this very
uneasy coalition with the prime minister
benjamin netanyahu the bitter political
rivals have just fought
an election campaign against each other
and so
while gans is talking about working with
the us to ensure that any deal
meets israel's needs and expectations
benjamin netanyahu has been talking very
vociferously as he long has for many
years against any idea
of such a deal israel has
reportedly put some very strict criteria
behind what it would accept but they're
so strict from the israeli perspective
that
it's very unlikely that any of them or
at least not all of them could be met
in any deal going forward and so what
he's been saying at the same time as
these talks have been going on
in vienna last week is that any
agreement
that would pave the way for iran to have
a nuclear weapon
in the future is one that israel would
not be bound by
and so obviously that's talking about
freedom of action in the context
that we've just been hearing now the the
meeting that we've had today
between gantz and the lloyd austin the
u.s secretary of state
has been one which they've been talking
fairly uh
positively about the long-standing
us alliance talking about plans for
future military acquisitions in the
future and so this is what lloyd austin
had to say our commitment to israel
is enduring and it is ironclad
and i pledge to continue close
consultations in order to ensure
israel's qualitative military edge and
to strengthen
israel's security and harry as
assad in tehran alluded to this is
coming at a time of
maritime conflict a shadow maritime
conflict anyway
uh playing out between israel and iran
is that likely to feature in the
discussions in israel
well yes i mean there have been
discussions already and more
to take place and yes that is part of
the context
uh that netanyahu and others have been
talking about uh that there have been
these reports that for some time now
israel has been acting militarily
covertly
to interrupt uh iranian ships
taking oil to syria and then we've had
in february and march two israeli-owned
vessels
in the arabian sea that have been
attacked uh israel
uh reportedly uh or at least uh seems to
believe that is an iranian uh attack in
both cases
and then last week this uh explosion
under the water line of the savi's
vessel
a cargo ship used by the iranian
revolutionary guard corps
and again very fast turnaround of
leaks being reported in the new york
times in this instance
that israel was responsible for that no
official
uh confirmation of that from the israeli
government obviously but this is the key
thing that
israel appears to be taking these
measures against iran at the same time
as the united states is talking about
resuscitating
the jcpoa the iran nuclear deal so it
will be very interesting to see when
austin has his
meeting with netanyahu on monday whether
netanyahu like
gantz did talked about trying to make
the best
of a deal or whether he maintains this
very hard line
against the very idea of it thank you
for that harry fossett live for us here
in west jerusalem
well let's discuss all this further now
with hassan ahmadiyan who's an assistant
professor of middle east and north
african studies at the university of
tehran
is joining us via skype from the iranian
capital thank you very much for being
with us
uh a lot to talk about let's start with
this incident
at the natanz facility that iran
reported today certainly
very worrying every time there's an
incident at a nuclear facility
and now in the last hour the iranians
describing this as an attack
if they're saying this is an attack
first of all how much damage do you
think could have been sustained here
well it's not clear what
what happened exactly at the facility
obviously uh there are conflicting
reports but
his latest uh remarks suggest that there
were there has been an attack
we don't know what kind of attack is it
a cyber or
an act of uh you know uh physical
sabotage
we don't know that we we are yet to hear
about that but obviously uh the
conclusion is that
uh the the there is an act of
sabotage and uh and uh uh obviously
the israelis are to blame in such uh
circumstances
because uh previous you know uh
incidents
uh have uh pointed to israel as well so
it has a track record of the week
well there is no proof right now as to
israel's responsibility but certainly as
you say iran in the past has
blamed israel for such attacks there was
a fire at the natanz
facility last year which tehran blamed
on israel
this is all coming as uh the nuclear
talks are about to resume with the
united states
trying to revive the 2015 nuclear deal
if it is an attack and an act of
sabotage as the iranians are saying
how might it affect their position in
the negotiations
this can potentially have a negative
effect on the
negotiations obviously the israelis have
an interest
uh and and they have you know announced
uh
time and time again that they
would not like to see the jcpoa being
revived
and the united states getting back to
its commitments in
the jcpoa so the iranians will be asking
themselves whether these
kinds of attacks are in coordination
with the united states or not because
uh previously during the negotiations
leading up to the 2015 nuclear deal with
iran
the the united states has proved that it
can put a cap on the israeli
activities assassinations within iran
ukrainian
nuclear facilities or against its uh
scientists right
but now obviously the israelis are
increasing their attacks but there is no
uh acts uh on the part of the united
states
you you keep talking about israel and
the iranians uh certainly keep talking
about israel as
uh being responsible of what they're
calling act of sabotage but
israel is not the only country that has
concerns about the resumption
of the 2015 nuclear deal the saudis are
also very wary
it's not only about the intention it's
about the capabilities
the israelis uh many believe in iran
many believe that
the israelis and the united states are
the only parties that
are capable of doing these kinds of
attacks within iran
the saudis have didn't show previously
any
uh such capabilities so the points are
there the blame is pointed to the
israelis or the united states
and in in another scenario but obviously
uh taking the current negotiations
indirect negotiations between iran and
the united states into account
it's uh you know it's easy to conclude
that the
israelis who are on their toes uh on the
revival of the jcpoa are willing to do
uh something to affect that negatively
thank you for that thank you very much
for bringing us the viewpoint from iran
there
hassan hamadian joining us from tehran
thank you for your time
in other news jordan's king abdullah and
his half-brother have appeared together
for the first time since their political
rift
former crown prince hamza joined the